all right we are now live for another
AMA that is ask me anything session here
on YouTube for my channel and let me
just make sure everything is set up the
way we want it I see there's quite a few
questions already lined up which is cool
I'm glad to see those glad to have
everybody here popping in unfortunately
in the interface I can't actually see
how many people are in the the interface
but you know I'm guessing probably our
normal number maybe through sound input
volume down a little bit a little bit
loud with this mic set the way it is
alright so let's see we have here first
question is from mario wob dig have i
read the novel Steppenwolf by Hermann
Hesse and if I did have I related to
Harry Haller struggles no I haven't read
Steppenwolf the stuff that I read by
HESA there was a siddhartha and a few
other things but that I haven't read
Steppenwolf so it's one of those things
that eventually I might get to I get the
chance I kind of depends on how busy I
am but okay so Mario's bringing up this
thing between Nietzsche's Apollonian and
Dionysian I will say this peso like many
other people I think misunderstood
Nietzsche it's very common for artists
to take off from Nietzsche's birth of
tragedy and be like everything's
Apollonian or Dionysian and they totally
misunderstand the fact that the book is
you know 2/3 about a whole different
thing the third noble response to the
problem of life which is the Socratic
and then Alexandrian which is neither
Apollonian nor Deanna sein and actually
blocks both of them effectively it
misunderstands both so I don't know I I
haven't read that that particular piece
but I've seen a lot of artists and
novelists managed to misunderstand me
chew on that on that particular point
Adam how would you describe
philosophical thinking in contrast with
mathematical thinking the common feature
of both is working with abstractions so
it depends on whose philosophical
thinking we're talking about doesn't it
because it's not as if there's just one
single thing that we call philosophical
thinking I know there's there's a lot of
intro to philosophy textbooks and
there's a lot of like what is philosophy
books you know some of them written by
quite good philosophers who will try to
say you know well here's philosophical
thinking here's here's mathematical
thinking but I gotta say after years and
years of reading that sort of stuff I've
never found one where I'm totally
satisfied with a you might say monastic
conception of what philosophy is because
philosophy has been and meant many
things over the years and unless the you
know the model for philosophy is able to
take in a whole bunch of great
philosophers as paradigms I don't think
it's an adequate model you could say
that mathematical thinking and even that
is kind of kind of broad to write
mathematical thinking is at least
concerned with a certain range of
objects or ideas I mean plato was the
one who sort of kicks that that often or
you can say Pythagoras but we don't
really have that much by Pythagoras or
the pythagorean's until much later on
the plato definitely thinks that
mathematical objects numbers or
quantities and then geometric things are
they have their own peculiar mode of
existence you know that we have to reach
through through abstraction and and
there's you know sort of a at least a
distinction between the two going
forward from there but I don't think I
would try to even describe them in
contrasts with each other because
they're you know like I said philosophy
is pluralistic James Calder do you think
dumb people can be smart sure in the
sense of they can become smart but
oftentimes what that's going to require
is figuring out why they're dumb and
then trying to overcome some of those
you might say sources or or obstacles or
impediments that that that produced the
dumbness right so you know that's not
easy to do because if you were you know
really that smart you could say to the
person who's struggling with that
well you'd already be halfway along the
way I will say that a lot of people you
know the the the real obstacle this is a
little bit of a different answer to
studying philosophy in many cases is not
sheer intellectual ability it's it's
more like you know certain
misunderstandings that people have
gotten along the way and they've become
emotionally attached to like you know
they read a they encountered somebody
who taught philosophy or wrote about
philosophy and they got this idea
philosophy has to be what this person
says you know you see a lot of people
who you know are attracted to Thomism
for example taking out that that sort of
view or people who are trained in
analytic philosophy you know an analytic
philosophy is an incredibly wide field
as well so there's like different ways
of doing it that are sometimes not
viewed as compatible with each other
so there's there's those sorts of things
expecting philosophy to be just like
other disciplines that one studies
another sort of problem I think that
comes up being unwilling to entertain
ideas that one doesn't agree with
without immediately trying to look for
the you know weak points or something
like that that keeps people from
learning it's it's difficult to study
philosophy and make much progress unless
you are at least willing to see where
Descartes is going or where this you
know latest theorist is is going with
their ideas before you jump on and say I
know exactly what that is right and and
then condemned it all right shaf Alikhan
can you explain the reasoning behind
George Berkeley is to be is to be
perceived in his own
to logical argument for gun I don't know
that um that Berkeley has an ontological
argument for God as a matter of fact he
considers God just as he considers us to
be spirits there what lie behind the the
perceptible phenomenon and and that to
be is to be perceived has to be
understood in two different ways right
there's the things that we actually do
perceive which are ideas not material
realities according to Berkeley but then
there's the things lying behind those
ideas which we don't directly perceive
like spirits and we think that those are
responsible for those ideas and he
thinks that God is is one of them you
know one way of thinking about Berkeley
and metaphysics and epistemology is he
really is committed to this notion that
to be is to be perceived and that means
that when we stop perceiving something
it would it would stop to you know to
exist right it would no longer be except
for the fact that you have God and God
provides a certain kind of consistency
and constancy to our array of
perceptions so without if you take God
out of the picture it would be a chaos
wouldn't it then you'd never really be
able to be sure of anything that you're
you're seeing chef also asked and shed
some light on Conte and morals well I
don't know what you want I mean that's
kind of complicated
I've got like what twenty odd videos
just on contour the metaphysics of
morals because it's not something easily
summed up I mean you can say well you
know categorical imperative in its three
formulations is at the key or at the at
the core of it and that's that's true
but I mean that's only in the groundwork
to then we have you know the second
critique and religion within the limits
of reason alone which is really a book
of ethics and the actual groundwork for
the are the actual metaphysics of morals
which is two parts and the doctrine of
virtue and the doctrine of justice in
all these other writings so I mean what
you can say
as I can't really is concerned with the
notion of duty and he thinks that that
you know we can conceptualize that
through laws that we recognize and then
impose upon ourselves and either follow
or don't follow and that our autonomy
consists in large part in extricate
ourselves from you might call it the
stimulus response audit automaticity of
psychological laws you know or did ways
of determination I think that's probably
a good enough sum up for for here you
know it's this isn't like a session
where we just go deep into any
particular thinker all right chip any
favorite or most recommended works by
John Cassian there's not much by the guy
you know we have the constant we have
the conferences and then we have the
Institute's
and then there's this treatise on the
incarnation of the Lord which nobody
ever reads but it's kind of interesting
but had almost no influence on on the
history of philosophy the Institute's
and the conferences that's really
interesting stuff the conference's are
these recordings of conversations that
cassian and his fellow traveling monk
had with all of these Abbott's over the
course of years in the Egyptian desert
and they're they're you know thinking
out issues oftentimes in terms of a sort
of neoplatonist anthropology but applied
to you know the spiritual life in in in
a Christian context these are people who
were experimentally involved right
trying to figure out how to make things
work and then you have the the
Institute's which is sort of a blueprint
for what a monastic community would look
like and a major discussion of the eight
capital vices which later on become as I
think everybody knows the seven deadly
sins right so those are the works to
read by calcium you notice that
st. Benedict in Benedict's rule very
important in western monasticism
recommends Cassian is one of the the
read the authors who ought to be read by
by monks so that they can understand the
spiritual life and the demands of
monasticism james kaulder what do I
think of Chomsky I think he's
interesting but I don't buy into whose
linguistic stuff very much you know and
I'll say this he's he's consistent and I
admire consistency so that's good
Gabriel have I thought of making a video
series on the history and many
iterations of the ontological argument
yeah I mean I've thought of writing
stuff on that as well
one of my very early conference papers
was was precisely about that at the
second no the first st. Anselm
conference at Saint Anselm College
sponsored by the Institute for Saint
Anselm studies right and you know I made
I made you some work on that eventually
you know it would be kind of fun to do
some some like ideas in history and
trace out what's done with them and
where they go and who says what and why
they say it but there's that be a matter
of finding the time all right
AP what's my opinion on the speculative
realist movement not sure what that is
I think I'm a beacon mixing that up with
another speculative something or other
if we're talking about like the Graham
Hartmann type of people it's interesting
I don't see it as making any really
major new contribution it was it was
sort of like that you know 15 years ago
what do you think about radical
orthodoxy well it's interesting stuff
they're doing but I don't see a lot of
legs on this I could be wrong but I'd
you know be more willing to spend my
time reading more classical texts than
all right
Nicholas Hamilton what was my high
school in college I went to Catholic
Memorial not far from here down the road
in Waukesha went to Lakeland College
this is all stuff you can find easily on
my website and my bio and then I went to
Southern Illinois for graduate study
down in Carbondale let's see here so
Olson asks a kind of vague question do
you any amount of philosophy can
actually fix all of us so I imagine
that's about can philosophy fix the
screwed up worth we find ourselves in
right and the answer is yeah to some
degree but I mean don't expect it to be
a magic bullet that you know kill kills
every evil and takes care of everything
you got a philosophy takes a while to
study not all of it is directly
applicable to working on complicated
problems some of its kind of you know a
little cul-de-sacs over here and there
and it takes a while to you know so get
it to to work both the in applying it
and getting other people to buy into it
and even in getting oneself sort of
wrapped around it you know it's often
involves changing one's habits and
developing resources that one didn't
originally have but yeah I mean
philosophy has plenty of you know
potential for making things better
usually not all by itself usually in
conjunction with other things so for
example if you're doing philosophical
counseling like I do you probably want
to know a good bit about psychology
yes well alright and you know if you're
gonna talk to business people you gotta
actually know something about the
business world and how it works and you
got to be able to communicate across
disciplines so Adam asks what is the
Hegelian idea there is no one hey
Galleon idea there's a number of
different ideas if we're talking about
like key concepts of Hegel if you mean
like
is what does Hegel mean by the idea it
depends on what stage of what you're
you're looking at right I will say this
that for Hegel it's incredibly important
that that ideas are not understood is
purely speculative but as inherently
practical so that they they attain their
their reality their vehicle Iike chiton
German their actuality in being
institutionalized and being lived out
and that's often how we we tell what's
in an idea as opposed to what it's just
presented as at the start so that's
important Adam asks where do I stand in
the fact value dichotomy debate I don't
know that there's a debate about that if
there is I missed it
there's what there's a lot of
discussions about you know is there a
fundamental difference between facts and
values every attempt to try to classify
those rigidly apart from each other
fails I mean because these are sort of
ground concepts you need both of them
involved to make any sense of things I
mean you know you can even talk as
Nietzsche does about like the will to
truth right and you know this desire for
facts that would be something different
from from values
it's driven by values I mean again this
is sort of a not just a Nietzsche point
there's also a Hegel point right Hegel
recognized that very clearly oftentimes
it gets it gets conflated with the is
ought to sting ssin and that often gets
you know drawn out of out of Hume
although there's other authors who make
similar distinctions but I read Hume not
as saying oh there's this fundamental
difference between is and art and you
can't get an A not from an is well you
never get a lot from an is because
there's always all these these
background thoughts in play and it's
just a question of bringing him to light
and taking a look at them and seeing if
they're valid or not or what context
they're valid in I think a lot of people
like to they like these nice simple you
know dichotomies that then they can try
to you know classify everything into and
then the work of philosophy is over but
you know
academies are only as good as their
their applicability and they need to be
consistent as well they need to be self
consistent so yeah alright Xena
what's my view on contra fusible to
Anselm's ontological argument for God's
existence so can't I should point this
out not only does he he reject the
ontological argument saying that
existence is not a predicate he also
views and sums arguments or not Anselm
sorry ontological arguments right
because actually he's not actually
representing Anselm the only time that I
know that he actually takes on ants on
this such as his lectures on what
philosophy of religion or something like
that no that's that's that that's that's
not the right title but there's there's
a work of lectures where he actually
does look carefully at something like
and stones argument what you have in the
first critique is not Anselm's argument
but that's because most people think
that you know Anselm's argument is what
what people make of it later Anselm's
argument is what's in the pro slow Gian
there's other ontological arguments like
that of Descartes for example or Spinoza
or other people and so Kant thinks not
only that the ontological argument is is
you know good for that cosmological and
teleological arguments in some secret
way depend on the ontological argument I
think both I think both of those are
mistaken on counts parts but I think
that's because can't you know he's got
his particular way of approaching things
so there's literally no room within his
system for something like an ontological
argument that would would be any good
and I think he's wrong with with
construing the other arguments is in
some way dependent on it but it's
understandable once you look at Kant's
project so you know but I you know when
it comes to the ontological argument I
go back and forth and back and forth
about how good of an argument it is
which makes perfect sense because Anselm
himself did write as did other
interpreters of
and ontological arguments are Jonas
what's the earliest definition of this
subject in philosophy so that's kind of
a trick question
I would say it's an Aristotle but it
doesn't mean what you think it means
because subject them it's the Latin for
it is the Hoople came a known in Greek
that which underlies right and it's it's
the thing that other things are
predicated of or the thing that other
things can can be in right like
knowledge in your mind and what we mean
quite often is like subject versus
object and it's important to know that
over the history of ideas these terms
have almost like flipped meaning in in
many cases right so what we would call
an object in in earlier times would be
called a subject who's the first person
to use it like in the term of
subjectivity I'm not quite sure
certainly that's coming out quite a bit
in the modern age it's becoming almost
an obsession with them what is what is
the subject you know what is personal
identity you know can we be sure of
anything that we're knowing about the
outside world or are we imprisoned
within the realm of our ideas about it I
don't know it's a good question I would
hesitate to say any particular person
just in part because you know although
the concept might be there they might
not be using that particular term right
all right Sebastian a lot of Kant's
stuff today do you think Conte was right
about the AA priori synthetic statements
the what about the a very synthetic
statements that they exist that that
they can be grounded or justified I mean
what are you what are you asking it's
now I can't just you know said a priori
synthetic statements or propositions and
boom there it is he said an awful lot of
stuff about that are you talking about
you know the possibility
of them which is you know being dealt
with in multiple works I think it's
important when we ask these questions to
figure out exactly what we're asking
about Kyle do you think it's accurate to
say that Hegel's God is more of a ground
of all being lower power than a higher
power
um ground of all being that sounds very
Tillich in no I wouldn't say that
Hegel's got is more of a ground of all
being than a higher power
I mean Hegel doesn't think that miracles
occur and he doesn't believe in God
in you could say a classical theists
sense as like a creator of everything
but he does think of God as as
definitely as a higher power that we
sort of come to recognize ourselves in
the community as being so it's not just
like a ground of being you know or like
the thing that underlies everything else
[Music]
I'm not sure these these I'm not sure
these are the best ways to describe
Angles conception of God
all right David likes my jacket sweater
yeah is the the dude sweater from The
Big Lebowski my wife got it for me
several Christmases ago and it's very
comfortable and the reason she got it
for me is because so many people in
videos were saying well this guy looks
like the dude right and I've always
meant to do some videos where I would
like take the glasses off and or maybe
I'll use my old glasses and have more of
the glasses like he had and you know say
a few things with with the sort of
dialect that he uses in there but about
philosophy or something like that but
you know like so many other things I
don't know if all if I'll get to it
Abdulla
do I feel about people that call
themselves philosophers even though they
have no background in philosophy well
that used to really tick me off right
used to really tick me off when somebody
would say my philosophy of coaching is
blob and a blob of law because I'd be
like you don't know what the word
philosophy means and you should stop
using it but I don't I don't get too
worked up about those sort of things
anymore because it's not like my getting
upset about that is going to change the
language or change their attitudes it's
better if I can actually steer them into
studying some real philosophy and that's
oftentimes done better by engaging them
in conversation I don't know too many
people who call themselves philosophers
these days even though they have no
background whatsoever in in philosophy I
know a lot of people who get called
philosophers by other people who don't
have much of a background but that's
because those people are ignorant of
what philosophy actually is or they're
selling something they're trying to
peddle some somewheres and they think
philosophy sounds cool I will say that
it kind of does suck that there is a I
think it's a makeup or cosmetics or
maybe massage oils product line maybe
perfumes that has the name philosophy
because it tends to screw up Google
results it's when you're when you're
googling actual philosophy but I think
most people can very quickly tell the
difference between those alright Beckley
I recently got started in stoic
philosophy at the end creating it's
sometimes hard to remember principles in
real time what would you suggest
well practice practice practice just
like the enchiridion tells you you know
it's it's you know one of those things
where the more that you do it the better
you get at it another thing that you
might think about doing is sitting down
and thinking about the more common
situations that you find yourself in
where afterwards you're like damn I wish
I could have remembered that thing from
Epictetus and then rehearse those ahead
time so that you actually will remember
those you know the enchiridion is also
incredibly short it's easy to carry
around on your phone or you can eat I
mean it's literally that the book that
goes in your hand you could you could do
that as well
so that could be quite quite helpful as
you know as well and you know you're
gonna want to you're gonna get more out
of it the more stoic philosophy you
study it's just stoic philosophy is a
systematic whole just actually posting
about this yesterday or not yesterday
but today in the the article that I
wrote for stoicism today Seneca is asked
by Luc Ilyas hang can you give me some
Maxim's now Maxim's are these little
quotes that people pop out right and
there's a lot of people putting them on
Twitter or Facebook you know with a
little head of epic Tina so often times
they get Epicurus his head instead
because they don't know the difference
between the two and then it'll have like
a little line or something and Seneca
says well I don't really want to give
you Maxim's because that's liable to
mislead you stoic philosophy as a whole
it you know when you're only grasping a
little part of it it doesn't stick quite
as well and then he's like well but I'll
give you some anyway right but just
understand that these are all
interconnected with each other so the
more that you study stoic philosophy and
this would go for any sort of
intentional way of life whether it's
philosophical religious or some some
other you know path where you're trying
to restructure your your faculty of
choice and restructure your thinking and
restructure your emotions there's going
to be some sort of systematic
comprehensive thing or it's all [ __ ]
there's nothing systematic about it then
it's just life hacky stuff right in
which case you do whatever you want with
that but the real stuff is actually
going to be rather systematic and then
you have to figure out how to to apply
it and the more that you do that the
better you're going to get at it when
you first start out you're gonna you're
gonna fail most of the time that's just
the way it is with with anything just
like when you first go to
the gym you're gonna you know feel
really uncomfortable and out of place on
the machines and then eventually you can
figure out how they work and you start
lifting more and more weight and your
body is adapting itself it's the same
way with with philosophies so alright
five five five three through seven have
you ever left angry notes and the
margins of philosophy books you
disagreed with yes I not for a long time
thankfully I don't actually write much
in books anymore in part because I
realized that I rarely you know find the
stuff that I wrote previously in the
books to be all that helpful or
insightful and I'm like man who the hell
wrote this crap right and but I have
yeah I've done that with with books I
think the last time I did that I was in
graduate school so it's been quite a
while since I did that Jeremy are you a
fan of philip k dick is so what's
perhaps your favorite work yeah I'm a
big fan of Phil okay dick I mean I've
done videos about his work and I talk
about him in a lot of different so
someday I'd actually like to do a Dick's
Dickensian glossary and it would like be
sort of a there'd be more than a
glossary it would be like all the
different you know concepts from
theology philosophy psychology and a few
other places that are in his works
little discussions of each of them so
that would aid you know a reader who
doesn't actually have the sort of
background that dick himself had to be
able to figure out what all the
references are and what's going on in
his works because there's a lot of
really there's a lot of things going on
right and I really like philip k dick in
part because he can take a a concept and
without sort of slavishly following it
he can embody it he can have it be part
of the dialogue he can have it be part
of the characters inner thought
processes and you can learn something
about the philosophical
or theological or whatever concept from
reading his works I think that's really
cool and I think that's kind of rare to
other people you know you think about
aimed and Voigt with you know his
version of libertarianism in like the
weapon shops of Ishar and Holly and that
sort of thing he was doing something
kind of similar as well and of course he
influenced dick so yeah I really I
really enjoy dick now which which is my
favorite work I would have to say if I
could only pick one and that is that is
tough I mean I go back and forth which
is at this point in time I would say a
Scanner Darkly I mean if you'd asked me
a year ago I'm going to said man in the
high castle and that's really a great
work too but Scanner Darkly maybe more
then there's you know he's one of my
guilty pleasure readings fortunately we
have a great you know collection of him
in the library just down the road so far
all right Nicola does need to support
capitalism I don't know if he critiques
it I know about socialism and equality
socialism he interpreted as a political
doctrine and he was critical of that he
was critical of democracy he was
certainly critical of the modern
tendency to reduce everything to its
cash value and he would see capitalism
as a as a system and remember the
capitalism doesn't name just one system
it retains a whole bunch of different
systems that that proceeded from each
other there's no one single thing out
there with a capital C capitalism but
Nietzsche would say that that's just as
crap as socialism is just as as
conformist just any I mean you see this
you know go on Twitter for example and
look at look at the the capitalist
apologist arguing with the socialist
apologist almost all of them are just
you know joiners and you know repeating
sort of stock lines convinced of the
rightness of their side worshiping some
some you know thing that they think is
gonna you know somehow you know reward
them for their their self abasement of
posting continuously in its defense and
you know I need to
I mean Nietzsche probably would be
willing to say that you might find some
people of his you know along the lines
of his master morality or whatever
whatever it is that's supposed to come
after that it with a new transvaluation
of values you might find people like
that as captains of industry but that's
really more ein Rand than Friedrich
Nietzsche I think nature would would
look at you know a lot of these people
as just like damaged goods who don't I
mean here's the thing Nietzsche and Marx
actually go quite well together when
we're thinking about like deformations
of consciousness so I mean so does Freud
too if you get away from some of the you
know crazy stuff and you actually take
the things that are useful from from him
and that's why paul ricoeur called
nietzsche Marx and Freud the you know
masters of the hermeneutics of suspicion
so you know now there's another thing
that well would Nietzsche then have been
like against capitalism in the sense
that he wouldn't have sold his books no
I tried to solving these books everyone
has to earn a living there's many ways
of critiquing or being against or
partially divesting oneself from or
trying to find an alternative to
capitalism and it's not an
all-or-nothing thing but yeah I think in
general he would have viewed it and it's
interesting because look at mock
Schaller who is a catholic
phenomenologist who adopts nietzsche and
thinks nietzsche has got a lot of things
right read a short book rose on too much
for that Schaller ties nature's critique
directly to this you know new sort of
industrial system of capitalism and
talks about how you know the reduction
of everything to to essentially use
value utility is is a real problem all
right let me say one other thing to what
does nature support nietzsche supports
the individual and a lot of times today
here in America especially but it's also
growing in other places I mean it's
funny that that they're like you know my
Brazilian colleagues and interlocutors
were just a couple years ago saying
there's a lot of people reading mine ran
down here and I was like really what's
going on with that there's a lot of
people who think that like capitalism
Foster's the individual no capitalism
itself does not capitalism opens up
certain spaces and then closes them off
quite frankly very very much at the time
where individuals can thrive you know
the small business owner the the
innovator the the person who is is
developing something new that is an
expression of their desire to to create
that's something that capitalism makes
possible so does socialism just as much
as capitalism does because capitalism
closes the doors for so many people as
does socialism as do other things like
you know Islamic clericalism or other
ways of organizing the economy Nietzsche
is interested in individuals who
actually have some Dyna Missa tee to
them developing themselves and not
taking their cues from you know say
reading you know actually miss reading
Adam Smith Adam Smith would not be for
anything you know he wouldn't think a
look at our capitalist system today and
he'd be like this is [ __ ] this is
not what I was talking about quit using
me in many respects he was talking about
small manufacturers and where there
isn't a you know a focus on creating
actual goods and services not just on a
you know maximizing shareholder value or
gobbling up all the other companies so
you can keep them from innovating and
threatening you or any of those sort of
stuff or the incredible interpenetration
of corporations in our political system
on both you know party sides Nietzsche
you know and even Adam Smith would have
said that's that's crap
I'm interested in the value of
individuals being able to creatively
develop so all right MJ what measures
can we take to true
understand philosophical arguments there
are certain arguments no matter how hard
I try I find I cannot fully grasp was
there a method you use well maybe
they're not arguments philosophy is way
more than just arguments it's also
explanations it's also accounts it's
also distinctions it's also practical
exercises and experimentation so maybe
you could be mistaking those things for
arguments and trying to treat them like
arguments and then being surprised when
they're not as amenable to that
treatment I mean the other thing is you
got to you got to work at this stuff so
I'm some maybe pre if they are genuine
arguments they may be presupposed in
that you have background knowledge about
something there's no one-size-fit-all
for this but just keeping at it and and
trying to you know learn more about the
stuff that you're working with and then
eventually getting your head around it
and maybe you only get your head around
it half way that's still making some
progress though isn't it all right
arge honest where does Foucault begin is
is it his epistemology to culminate with
the death of the subject well I mean you
can read his early stuff right and read
um you can also read like the four words
and like conclusions as well that
that'll give you some idea Nietzsche was
really important for Foucault he talks
about this I believe in madness and
civilization or it might be in
discipline and punish he's talking about
like the the effect that that like
Nietzsche had coming on to the scene
again not because he wasn't like coming
out of the scene for the first time for
his his his generation of intellectuals
who are you know at that time you had
you know sort of structuralism going on
you had these AG aliens and Marxists out
there you had existentialists and you
know nietzsche didn't fit in neatly into
any of those i understand so lo he was
an existential so you have an
existential
was a wide movement right and the nature
that they're interested in is the one
who's doing cultural critique so I would
say that that's part of it and then
Foucault himself it's funny he says I'm
not a structuralist he's a structuralist
as hell in in the archeology of
knowledge and the order of things I mean
you can actually create grow mozzie and
squares out of what he's doing so so you
know he's doing a little bit of lying to
his audience and saying I'm not a
structuralist but he's drawing and then
he's trying to be he's trying to go
beyond that you know so now where does
he begin he begins by doing research
begins by going to archives by studying
by not taking things for granted as the
narrative of how things actually are but
but actually reading text one of the
good things about Foucault is he's not
always right about stuff as a matter of
fact I think quite often he's drawn
wrong conclusions about some things but
he will direct you to get to some of the
interesting text that you want to read
along the way and sometimes he actually
is right about things distinction
between different modes of exercise of
power I think is really great the notion
of technologies the self not unique to
him but but the way he's doing it pretty
good stuff you know I like I like his
project all right Becky Beckley do the
Stoics have any advice for letting go of
Roseanne tamam a resentment yeah you
gotta examine why your resentment is
arising and figure out what you can
actually do about that where where the
assumptions that you're making you're
off base then you have to practice
practice practice practice practice and
it's probably good to actually find a
community of people who are engaged in
similar sort of things any intentional
way of living as a philosophy involves a
lot of practicing a lot of self scrutiny
a lot of trying to make some progress
along the way so that's that's part of
it and actually epictetus and Seneca
themselves have a lot to say so does
marcus aurelius about anger and
and how it arises and they could be a
lot of different techniques that you can
use I have a video that you can you can
check out from stoic on 2016 it was a
workshop session that I did specifically
on stoicism an anger that might be
helpful for you as well let's see
Tyler s is des cartes race extensa about
dualism yeah well it is
I mean race extensa is things that are
extended material things not thought des
cartes ontology is pretty simple and
straightforward you got extended
substances you got thinking substances
and you got God whatever God happens to
be and then you know how do we connect
up the the extended and the thought
that's you know the pineal gland or
however else we're gonna do it you know
there's this is one of the things were
the Cartesians themselves had to come up
with different ideas I mean Spinoza who
is a Cartesian right his very first book
principles of Cartesian philosophy he's
like well this isn't gonna work
they're both aspects are the same thing
and there's just one of them by the way
mall branch has this occasional ism
right different people have other other
accounts to try to make sense of it Tony
asks are there any good philosophical
conferences held in the Midwest yeah and
you can you can think of them in in
three different ways
so there's traveling conferences right
which are good conferences most of the
time anyway and sometimes there in the
Midwest and sometimes there in other
places like I like to go to the American
Catholic Philosophical Association not
only because the papers if it's a good
theme and a good committee are usually
pretty pretty good stuff but they have
all these satellite sessions you know
that I like to go through like the
eighty and Jill soul society the the
Institute for Saint Anselm studies will
have a session or the Gabrielle Marcel
Society right when I presented at a
number
those know if it's a crap theme then you
know it's probably not gonna be very
good but you know it's been in different
places I mean in in recent years it was
here in in Milwaukee just how many years
ago is like 2007 I think so 12 years ago
I think they're in South Bend sometime
in the future I don't know why that I I
only check if I've got something that I
think I can send out there so I don't
follow it too closely but you also have
the you know American Philosophical
Association there's all sorts of other
good organizations and what I mean by
good is not I mean the APA I'm not
really bullish on them but you can find
some interesting stuff right you can
find some stuff that's worth going to
and it travels around right sometimes
the Central Division will be at the
Palmer House Hilton down Chicago so
that's one kind of good conference to go
to and then you have the state
philosophical associations I can only
talk about the Wisconsin Philosophical
Association and the Indiana
Philosophical Association I used to be
very active in the IPA and I
occasionally go to the Wisconsin one you
know those those are decent you can you
know meet some local people and every
state has one it's worth checking out
I've also been in the North Carolina
Philosophical Association when I was
living down there and then you have
other conferences that are really well
worth looking at and going to because
they have there they're always like the
same place so I'll give you an example
of this
every summer whether I'm presenting or
not I go to Marquette's Aristotle and
the Aristotelian tradition conference
because it's amazing and it's it's you
know fairly inexpensive to go and it's
it's really worth going to and it's here
in Milwaukee hosted at Marquette
University in the last three days and I
get to see some some top-notch Aristotle
and other scholars presenting on things
and maybe sometimes I give a paper and I
chat with people and catch up with them
so you just got a like
keep your eyes open for for the
different things that are available if
you're in Indiana South Bend Notre Dame
has quite a few conferences on their
campus that are that are quite good
sometimes they're a bit more pricey of
course and so you just gotta you know
keep keep your eye out for that sort of
thing but there's yep there's plenty of
good philosophical conferences in the
Midwest dan the man do I have any
thoughts on anthroposophy several years
ago my high school philosophy teacher
was an anthropologist einar's system and
I think that Steiner had some
interesting things to say I was gonna
say a few but actually there's there's
some more than just a few but I I don't
buy into his his system and I think most
of the people who are doing it are very
new AG types it's more of a belief
system than an actual you know well
reasoned evidentially based kind of kind
of system Steiner was kind of a let's
draw everything in and see if we can
like rework it and it's very
comprehensive you know all the way from
you know theories of color which are
quite interesting he was very influenced
by Gerdes color theory you know to music
to agriculture to this and that and it's
all based on sort of the theory
correspondences I have actually been to
the GU Tiananmen dorte knock-on
Switzerland and visited that you know
while I was nearby and in beyond and you
know it's it's an interesting stuff I
don't buy any of that myself but I know
I know people who do all right
how can was from Ava how can we be more
aware of our faults flaws and character
and approach to how we see interpret the
world if we can't ask friends and have
to rely on our own limited POV well
there's nothing that says you can't ask
rats you know you can't ask your friends
they may not always give you good
answers but
you know you can find other people I
would say you probably do need to become
part of a community and you know you can
also find a lot of resources for
engaging in some self scrutiny from
philosophical or religious or
psychological traditions there's there's
many different options available out
there and and some of them you know you
might not by totally into it like you
know thinking about positive psychology
right this the you know selling man
stuff so I think a lot of that is
actually not very scientific like it
pretends to be because it relies so much
on like self reporting and and all that
and I think that the emphasis on like
preponderance of positive over negative
emotions and the stress on like getting
rid of negative emotions I think that's
in some ways misguided and I think the
way that they define things is off base
but can you like take their inventories
and learn something from them sure you
know you don't to buy into their their
thing in order to get something out of
it so it could be useful
Baban asked why are we conscious of the
world at all as opposed to being
unconscious the animals so to speak who
says animals are unconscious I mean the
classical definition of animals are
sentient beings I don't know you know I
know I'm not sure where that's coming
from but that's the kind of being that
we are why are we conscious of the world
at all because we respond to it and
we're engaged with it by the time that
we can frame that as a as an issue there
isn't any live possibility of us as the
beings that we are being unconscious of
right Zama asks what do I think about
Freud about how his theories affected
philosophical thinking oh that's a
that's a really interesting one so like
I'll go on from the record right now and
say I think the Oedipus complex stuff
was all nonsense you know maybe maybe
there's some people who do in fact
generally have an Oedipus complex but I
think Freud really oversold that one
at all and the stages you know of
development I think that's you know in
this hydraulic theory of repression and
emotions or activity there's a lot of
things we're gonna be like yeah Freud
mmm not not buying it and a lot of that
stuff of the stuff that caught on right
I will say this I do think the notion
that we have unconscious desires that
can be brought to light through depth
psychology is a very good insight I do
think that Freud furnished some some
useful ideas and insights that could be
taken up by other authors and
transformed and made more powerful I
think that Freudianism is you know it
turned into something almost like its
own sort of religion right with its own
high high priesthood initiations and
things like that but I don't think that
that it's all nonsense Alistair McIntyre
who does in fact take Freud seriously I
you know when I was in that seminar with
him there were three Alistair MacIntyre
always likes to contrast three things
against each other so we looked at
rational choice theory and its origins
in human and Hobbesian you know ways of
looking at things and we looked at
Aristotelian Thomism and then we looked
at Freud and Lacan and now why would
MacIntyre be it well I also Winnicott
too and inclined people like that
why would MacIntyre be interested
because he actually took that notion of
unconscious desire seriously as well and
he saw that the Freudians sometimes even
despite themselves were able to produce
some results
now people oh you know they've been
scientifically debunked kinda but also
kinda not right depends on how you how
you construe it you don't want to rely
on popular science or popular
psychologists tougher for your
assessment of them MacIntyre noted that
that within it is in his book the
unconscious that because of the
prevalence of Freudianism and all of his
sort of spin-offs and acolytes and
people doing similar
there is this tendency for an appeal to
Freudian concepts to justify what one
was doing I'm doing this because I'm
repressed and and you know I mean people
do this today right they they bring in
things from from other psychological
theories as well so look at all the
stuff about triggering and PTSD you know
and you get you know serious combat vets
and rape survivors telling all these
people who say I thought I didn't come
out right I'm triggered or somebody said
something mean to me I'm triggered and
they're like you're not triggered you
know that it actually means something to
to those of us but there's a tendency
for this to happen with with ideas they
make their way into the popular culture
and then they become part of the way we
relate to each other
so now philosophical thinking people
some people thought they should take
Freud seriously others thought that they
didn't need to and you know a lot of
continental thinkers have used Freud in
one way or another
some like Sartre would you know contrast
what he was doing in his existential
existense existential psychoanalysis
existential psychology from what the
Freudians were doing so and and john
wisdom actually was quite interested in
Freud as well on the analytic side so
you know there's been quite an important
influence all right Gabriel you
mentioned that you do not you once
mentioned you don't agree with emanation
and speaking of Neoplatonism can you
discuss your thoughts on why emanation
doesn't work for you well I'm not I'm
not a neoplatonist okay that's sort
I just don't buy this you know like
you've got the wand and then you've got
these various emanations coming out of
it there's nothing really mysterious
about it I just don't don't find those
accounts they're interesting but I just
don't find them compelling
Bertrand why is it most philosophy
departments only give tenure to Ivy
Leaguers over everyone else and make it
difficult for people who went to state
schools to move up to working at a
prestigious place well that's not the
case
philosophy departments give tenure on
the basis of research tenure service and
where you got your degree from is
probably not going to determine whether
they give you tenure I'm not sure where
that idea is coming from as a matter of
fact when you see Ivy Leaguers at
smaller institutions watch them
carefully there's probably a reason why
they couldn't get a higher tier job you
know and very often they don't stay
there they're looking at those as sort
of stepping stones and you know smart
search committees know that or tenure
committees know it's more difficult for
people who went to you know it's not so
much Ivy League versus state school some
state schools may as well be Ivy League
you know uw-madison for example when it
comes to philosophy certainly areas of
it you know they have just as much
prestige as somebody coming from
Dartmouth you know or even even you know
the Ivy Leaguers aren't all in the same
league either it's more like I view it's
more like elites let's call it versus
non elites and that has more to do with
whether whether you get in whether you
get your foot in the door and less to do
with whether you get tenure once you're
in the door you can you know do what
you're going to do and show them that
you're actually valuable getting in the
door is the tricky part getting to work
in a prestigious place when you don't
have a pedigree that they like that's
the tough part so all was the poison
O'Toole what would you think of like a
philosopher's mass like a church meeting
type thing just to meet discuss and talk
about daily problems with solutions and
practical philosophy like those and the
Stoics
well I wouldn't say it's like mass but I
would say that the meetings of the stoic
fellowship there's chapters all over the
world including here in Milwaukee are
like that that's what we do so also what
we do in Sofia another organization
society of philosophers in America that
has chapters all over the place
including here in Milwaukee there's
there's people doing that sort of thing
there have been people doing that for
for quite a while and I think it would
be great to have more of that as a
matter of fact that's one of the things
I want to try to promote here more in
the Milwaukee area but it's it's
certainly something that's already going
on and it could it be more like a mass
where you had a rather structured
liturgy I think it could but that might
turn some people off it's it's not like
stoicism has a breviary or you know an
order of ritual or something like that
so you know it kind of varies from place
to place but that's that's what a lot of
people are doing all right
maksim thoughts on girdle uh sure Bock
great book we actually spent a whole
semester on it when I was a
undergraduate because I was a
mathematics as well as a philosophy
major and so we did a special seminar
and we worked our way through girdle
Escher Bach that was a lot of fun I
really enjoyed that so as I remember it
was like a spring semester and it was
like a night class I think it meant once
a week or so and I just remember it
being really cold when cold and dark and
we'd get out of class but it's a that's
a great book
so Beckley can we practice philosophy in
conjunction with therapy many of us do
as a matter of fact you know a lot of
ancient philosophy is conceived as
therapy for the soul psychology comes
out of philosophy so yeah made of clay
is the postmodern scapegoating or
blaming justified also wise
post-modernism synonymous with kneel ism
because people are stupid and they don't
know what post-modernism means and they
probably don't even know what Neal ISM
means
the people who are like you know on the
right who are saying oh post-modernism
is the cause of this and that and this
and that they don't know what the hell
they're talking about
they've probably you know they've
probably been haven't read Wikipedia
articles on the people that they think
are responsible for the decline of
Western civilization and they're not
representative of anything valuable in
Western civilization even if they happen
to every once in a while break out
Cicero or the Stoics or something like
that this is something I've talked about
you know many times you can certainly
criticize you know post-modernism once
you have an idea of what what it means
and what what it encompasses but until
then it's just sort of you know saying I
don't like I don't like but a little you
know it's it's bleeding of goats
basically and it's funny too because if
you look in certain circles what a lot
of people today are complaining about is
post-modernism was previously called
modernism equally ambiguous term you
know so it's whenever I hear people you
know like going off on post-modernism I
know they don't know that the odds are
they don't know what the hell they're
talking about
so is it justified no are the things
that we should certainly you know
criticize or complain about turn well we
do those you know in a less blanket way
right
songho what do I know about Mishima
Yukio nothing
so can't say anything about that
shadowlink I'm trying to start Hegel
with your half-hour Hegel series I'm
wondering how relevant you believe Hegel
study is to today should I be studying
this over and over again in parts
Hegel's relevant Hegel's difficult to so
you got to evaluate whether you want to
spend the time on it and I don't think
that you you know you're not living a
good philosophical life you've never had
angle right but he's you know he's an
important person and and he's got some
interesting things to contribute so
that's one of those things where you got
to decide yourself whether you want to
do it Adam would I agree that philosophy
and love are all
tragic no I would say some love is
tragic and some philosophies tragic and
it's interesting how to rent in one of
her letters I think it was or maybe in
an address I've got a book marked on my
other computer she talks about
philosophy and love and friendship and
what was the other one maybe poetry as
being oasis in the desert of
contemporary life and so you know they
they provide us with a place to
replenish ourselves a place to get the
nourishment that is so often lacking in
modern society in part because things
that become homogenized and and the
depth has been taken out of them I think
it's a really profound insight so if
that's the case maybe the tragedy lies
outside of philosophy right love of
course can go wrong philosophy can go
wrong anything everything's vulnerable
to that but the idea that they would be
inherently or ultimately tragic I don't
I don't think so all right chef I'm 15
and tried reading thus Spoke Zarathustra
but did not understand much is it
because of my low vocabulary
I mean vocabulary can be an issue and
and vocabulary can be an issue in two
ways it could be you don't know what the
word is right so and that's something
you can remedy pretty easily I think the
other problem that arises quite often
with philosophy is that the the thinker
is using words that we might think we
know what they mean but they're used in
a different way and that that
philosophers you know something's much
more technical way and that philosophers
works and so then you read and you're
like oh so I understand what these words
mean but they don't add up right and
that's
sometimes that that gets better with
familiarization if you're reading stuff
at fifteen years old that's that's good
but you're not gonna get everything out
of it that you might get when you're
thirty and and that's okay there's no
remedy for that right there's no there's
no shortcuts there's no skipping ahead
but if you keep at it and keep keep
studying it you will understand more and
maybe read some other things as well
from from Nietzsche or read some
secondary literature on it too to help
you with it all right Kay Franklin what
would you suggest as an entry point to
philosophy for a new armchair
philosopher well I don't know what an
armchair philosopher even means but an
entry point pick anywhere you like I
mean wherever you enter in you're not
going to understand three quarters of
what you're reading at first and you're
gonna have to go back to it later anyway
pick something you you're gonna enjoy if
you like you know novels find somebody
who's a novelist who references
philosophy like Iris Murdoch for example
or you know GK Chesterton
philip k dick or you know if you want to
read some classic philosophy read some
classic philosophy it doesn't but you
know there's no like requirement of
where you're gonna start there's no best
place quite quite frankly if you like
you know like histories of of ideas you
know where it's kind of a summary of
stuff start with one of those cuz even
if it's crap like you know William
Durant's story of philosophy I read that
when I was an undergrad graduate I was
like well there's really great stuff and
then I read the Philosopher's he was
talking about I was like well he got
that wrong in that wrong in that wrong
at least he got something going right
same thing with like Bertrand Russell's
history of philosophy I think he's wrong
on a lot of points but you know he's a
good writer and he'll get you interested
in things just don't like take his this
is this way as gospel or anything like
that or you might like read some popular
works and they might get the philosophy
wrong too right
like played it with the Google plaques
or
swerve or any of those you know things
that are supposed to be about you know
philosophy written by a philosopher New
York Times bestseller list can't hurt
you no so long as you don't necessarily
believe that they've got it right so all
right uh Jeremy what are some excellent
works of literature written by non
philosophers that touch on some
existentialist concepts well there's
people in the existentialist tradition
like Franz Kafka right and of course
Rainer Maria Rilke is in there as well
you know
Fyodor Dostoevsky was not a philosopher
but he's important in the existentialist
canon and you know I mean philip k dick
is is somebody who often gets referenced
in that as well but I you know it's not
something I've given a lot of thought to
depends on what we mean by
existentialist if we're talking about
like being responsible for our choices
then I would say Graham Greene
you know fits into that but Greene I
think if you were to call them an
existentialist he'd be like don't
associate me with those degenerates you
know so there's there's a number of
people that you could you could pick up
on with that I'm not a big reader of
contemporary fiction so I don't you know
if it's been published since 1950 odds
are having read it just you know unless
it's sci-fi stuff or fantasy that I was
interested in all right
Beck Lee asked when he found out about
James Stockdale prison stint in Vietnam
and his credit to the enchiridion for
making him endure brutal conditions what
impression did you have well I found out
about that as I was reading through the
book that I was going to be teaching my
my Prison students at Indiana State
Prison and I was you know quite
impressed
I've known Stockdale as this guy who is
ross perot's running mate and man did
that make a bad impression when he was
in the vice presidential debates and I
was very pleasantly surprised to find
out that he was such a good writer and
that he had used epictetus at that time
was I was interested in stoicism but I
was not you could say attracted to
stoicism the way I was in the present
but many of my students in the prison
were not only attracted to stoicism but
studying stoicism and you know Stockdale
they they they responded to him quite a
bit okay let's see here the line of
things just jumped and I've lost my
place
let's get myself back to to do there's a
lot of questions here we're not gonna be
able to get to all these but all right
Carlo how do I start with studying the
postmodernist philosophers well figure
out who the postmodernist philosophers
are to begin with and some of them are
not going to call themselves postmodern
they'll get label this postmodern by
somebody else like for example dari down
right period I doesn't call himself a
postmodern he says he's doing
deconstruction he's doing other things
and you know I would say that one good
Avenue into that is to get Friedrich
Jamison's post-modernism block which is
pretty thick and it's got all these nice
references within it and explanations
and he sets out different models of what
post-modernism would be and then you
know like when you see something that
you like there say oh I want to like
follow up on that line and then that
could be useful for you Bob and what are
we supposed to do about the fact we
can't know exactly what we should do at
every moment in time or even in general
and the anxiety this develops well
realize that that doesn't have to make
you anxious because not everybody is
anxious in relation to that or caused by
that and then start looking at people
who aren't made anxious by that but
actually do have that insight and see
how they do things
talk to them see if you can adopt some
of those views for yourself
Valdemar I've not heard you talk about
the neoplatonist so what are your
thoughts on Prytania sand Pro class and
their pals you probably have done this
somewhere along your thousands of vids I
haven't done anything on them I'm not
you know I'm not a specialist I read
them you know and I do read them every
once in a while I find platonist very
interesting but I'm you know I'm not
attracted to that kind of Neoplatonism I
I'm you know if you had to say well what
kind of plate in a star you more of a
middle plate that's like Plutarch you
know kind of eclectic and and you know
so yeah alright bill Martens why would
Aristotle be a first wave feminist would
be a first wave I guess I guess a few if
he's a feminist he would have to be
first wave cuz he's before the you know
second wave point in fact Aristotle
isn't the feminist he says a lot of you
know clearly off base things about the
natural inferiority of women things that
he probably given his actual method and
his principles would have rejected where
he here in the present I'm actually done
talks on what I call Aristotle's woman
problem so I'm not sure where that that
is coming from but you know when we talk
about first wave feminism we're thinking
about the drive for equality it's less
about you know it's more about bringing
you know
undoing social structures that keep
women back about Mary Wollstonecraft for
example right undoing these vicious
cycles that that deprive women of
opportunities to develop which then
would allow them to actually be equals I
mean Wollstonecraft and Aristotle or
both virtue ethicists and and
Wollstonecraft actually not only says
that most you know most women are unable
to develop in their intellects and moral
capacities in the type of social
structures that we are living in back
then she also says most men are too
right so
all right Sebastian have you read naming
and necessity by Kripke is it worth
reading for someone interested in
philosophy of language yeah I read it in
graduate school I'm not a fan of Kripke
he's interesting he's he's somebody who
you know sure if you're gonna do
philosophy of language read him along
with a hundred other people right it's
it's okay he's got an interesting book
too and Vidkun Stein in private language
that's worth reading too Adam do I feel
stupid and confused after all these
years do it studying and doing
philosophy occasionally you know but not
often I mean I know you know what I do
know and I know how much I I've missed
out on and don't know and won't have the
time to actually study and read but you
know I'm kind of happy because with the
stuff that I've committed to and read
although I don't have all the answers
and all of the proper orientations the
things I have quite a few of them and
and I'm relatively happy with what I've
got going so yeah Daniel Cox can you
recommend any books on agape love or
political theology I don't I don't know
how those are connected together I get
paid I mean you could start with if you
if you want to distinguish that rigidly
from other types of love read CS Lewis's
the four loves and that'll get you
started then it'll refer you back to
Andhra sniggering and and you know other
thinkers who are making this distinction
I mean I don't really I don't think that
there's a rigid distinction in Greek
stuff even in the New Testament between
these different kinds of love but you
know it's it's okay always said no to
old thoughts on a united Ireland I don't
have any thoughts on that I'm not a you
know genetically I'm Irish but you know
I was raised in a family that's
french-canadian in ethnicity and I think
the Irish have to sort their own stuff
out have any I don't have any any
insight to contribute to them
all right Benjamin Dale I take it you
know how to read Latin did you find it
hard to learn I didn't find it hard to
learn but I have a facility with
languages and I also kind of you know
had some bits and pieces here along the
way too so like when I was in seventh
and sixth and seventh grade I went to a
school where we studied Latin and you
know was kind of like baby Latin you
could say right like we didn't even
learn the third declension until the
second year but you know they had that
and then when did I really start
studying it in earnest oh yeah when I
was in graduate school I I found an old
jag officer Army Field Manual to teach
yourself Latin and I used that and made
some progress with that and then
immediately went to try to read Cicero
and found that I was weighing over my
head and then instead of like taking
classes what I did is I just got the the
Latin grammar Allen and Greenough and
worked my way through it example after
example principle after principle but by
then I was already doing indo-european
linguistics so that you know that made
them a lot easier for me so and then you
know you read or authors and you learn
more stuff along the way so alright
Aristotle says that all men by desired
by nature desire to know any idea how he
came to that self-evident inductive no
idea I mean that's the beginning of the
metaphysics I would say it's probably an
inductive statement or maybe it's and
what we call an end doctor that he took
from somebody else whose texts we don't
have although usually Aristotle mentions
his sources so okay Baban asks why do
you think there were so many Lutheran
philosophers but not Calvinists I don't
know where you get that idea from there
were plenty of Calvinist philosophers
[Music]
you know just got to start digging
millennium I'm John Calvin himself
conceives of what he's doing as as
Christian philosophy I'm mark Trumbull
what is the connection between
Aristotle's four causes the unmoved
mover and stuff thinking thought so
that's a big scope question I mean the
unmoved mover would be you know in a way
the efficient cause Aristotle says at
some points that maybe God is like the
the you know this this final cause as
well self thinking thought I'm never
really sure what to make of self
thinking thought you know or you know no
ASIS thinking about itself it's not
something I find particularly attractive
about Aristotle's philosophy quite
frankly you know he's he's got a lot of
great tools and then he's got this sort
of like well we're gonna do this
contemplative philosophy over here
theoretical philosophy and you know the
goal is to be like God you know thought
thinking itself disengaged and then
you're like well what's all this other
stuff over here that you're so good at
all right Lou what do I think of
marijuana does it help open up your mind
in respect to new ways of thinking I
mean if it does then you didn't you were
really badly off to begin with I would
say you don't need it in order to do
that but it could be a useful cause I
suppose for some people but you know I
guess so good drinking or so could meth
in that case right so can so many other
things I think you know the main use for
marijuana there's really a couple one is
to alleviate pain and we're discovering
that it's quite good for for things and
it could be a way to get people off of
these opioids and I'm all for that
and then it you know it's a recreational
drug people like getting high and
there's a lot of that here in Milwaukee
man you can walk out on the street and
just get you know almost a contact high
at some points especially if you're
going to a concert I never I never
really was that interested in it you
know I tried it some
times but I found that the people that
were really into it were kind of dull
and so I you know when I was in graduate
school for example I much prefer
drinking than to smoking but that was me
okay so here's a question Deutz how many
pages of philosophy do you need to read
to be considered an intellectual you
tell me when you find that that's that's
like you know so so far away from there
like a body out there affirm somebody to
be an intellectual alright so there's
lots and lots and lots of questions I'm
about 10 minutes out from ending this
this session so I'm just gonna like jump
around now so a lot of people are you're
not going to get your questions answered
I tried to answer them in the order that
I did but you'll have to you know get in
on the next one I'll take what I can do
and we'll just jump around a bit I'm
actually gonna scroll down to the bottom
and then start scrolling up let's see
here stuff I can easily address well
here's a good one from Russell what's
the good life is there one singular good
life I don't think there is one singular
good life but I think there's like you
could say a family of good lives
connected to each other and there will
be some common elements to it I think
that you know Aaron Aristotle and the
other virtue ethicists are right that
virtue is gonna play a part in that
that's a term that often turns a lot of
people off because they've got like you
know moralistic conceptions of virtue
associated with that but if you look at
what the actual you know philosophers
say about about the virtues you can see
how they would they would be conducive
to that it also does take some luck some
fortune you know as Theophrastus
recognized but that's that's yeah that's
about it
let's see here due to Brian s do I have
an opinion on antinatalism you know the
people who are super for it they can
practice that whole they want right I
hear they're gonna run Thomas did I
still plan it as series I'm Maurice
blown down yeah I mean I plan to do a
lot of things on a lot of things it's
matter of finding the time and and
getting to it the more financially
independence of having to hustle and
work and teach and stuff like that that
I am through things like patreon the
more feasible that that sort of thing
becomes let's see
[Music]
Oh Alex when I
to speak about meister eckhart and
christian mystics not really i had a
good friend when i was in graduate
school who actually wrote his
dissertation on meister eckhart and we
talked quite a bit about it but I'm not
attracted to mysticism I know a lot of
other people are more power to them I'm
just not interested in doing that that
sort of thing and there's probably way
better people in in that that field
Victor asked I think a philosophy minor
would be worth pursuing yeah definitely
philosophy major is worth pursuing just
published a post the other day in rxs do
you know ntk about this weird assumption
that we have that you know the only use
for a philosophy degree would be like to
teach philosophy and how strange an
assumption that is all right here's a
good one from Niki do you think advances
in neuroscience could at some point help
us to get past some of the brick walls
we seem stuck on from trying explain and
understand consciousness from the
experience side no I doubt it
I mean insofar as it's neuroscience it's
not gonna help us explain consciousness
it can help us explain some of the
things that are going on that are
correlates to consciousness but you know
and neuroscience is one of those terms
it names everything from like really
rigorous research to complete [ __ ]
that just has the words neuro attached
to everything and everything in between
so you know there's a lot of people who
have some really incredibly optimistic
you know hopes for what neuroscience is
going to do and it's just a like a
repeat of the positivism of previous
ages with different kinds of science
involved I think neuroscience will
eventually sort of like come into its
own and be be reintegrated into the the
other Sciences and you know semiotic s--
you know will be just as important as a
neuroscience and people will talk across
those fields so you know that'll be good
alright
see says how can we find balance with
the principles of categorical imperative
and utilitarianism when utilitarianism
is about sacrificing one for all well
utilitarianism isn't about sacrificing
one for all that's not what it's about
it's about you know doing what's gonna
benefit the greatest number in some
cases that doesn't require sacrificing
one for all in some cases that does
require sacrificing a whole bunch for
the totality and how are you gonna find
balance
there isn't a balance between them you
know you pick one or pick the other or
pick some other point of view that's one
of those fundamental differences between
them you can't balance everything out
against each other
pensioner can have I read MOX Turner's
the ego in its own and if yes what's
your opinion so yeah I registered her
and and it's an interesting work and he
is you know very consistent which you
know I like in in the way that he's
working things out some people have
suggested that he should be imbued as a
as an existentialist and brought into
the existentialist Canon I you know I'm
willing to be convinced further along
those those lines you know I get what
he's doing and I find what he's doing
interesting but I I don't really buy by
it but I think there's things where we
can draw on it with the critical stuff
where it's it's it's quite useful Oliver
do i watch Rick and Morty or Game of
Thrones if so how do you like the shows
i watch both of them
I enjoy Rick and Morty quite a bit I'm
not happy with you know the sort of
dickish behavior a lot of Rick and Morty
fans thinking that because they've
grasped you know some of the clever
jokes in there that they're cleverer
than everybody else but I suppose that's
that's liable to happen with many kinds
of shows Game of Thrones I like you know
I like being able to watch it I'm not
I'm not happy about how off-book they
are and I'm not happy about the fact
that we've now got effectively two
different storylines
like totally different things have
happened and things are being
reinterpreted and in multiple ways
I suppose it's it's you know a factor of
the time that we live in we're lucky
that we actually have so many cool
series to watch but you know I'm I'm I'm
more of a fan of the book series than I
am of the show itself alright let's see
what else we'll take here boom all men
so here's a good one from killing
addiction I've studied philosophy for
nearly thirty years and taught it for
the past ten as a professor I'm curious
to hear about your biggest complaints or
frustrations as someone who has also
taught philosophy so you know was on the
teaching end I will say the frustrations
come in part from you know colleagues
and administration and in part from
students and with the students it's more
like you know you give them all these
great resources and then they they don't
they don't read them or they're not
engaged in them but you know that's
that's that right and and all I can do
is create openings I'm not going to like
try to force them into learning and and
they like the way I lecture and and you
know they show up to my classes so
that's good and I get more more requests
to teach then I can actually fill from
local institutions so that's good
I don't like the how you know sort of
rigid without thinking without
understanding that they're they're rigid
so many of my colleagues and the
administrators are about you know
teaching and and classes so you know for
example you know I'm designing a class
that's gonna be taught in the summer and
I've got these people saying video
shouldn't be any longer than 10 minutes
and I'm like you know the research
doesn't bear that out and people
sometimes watch videos that I produce
for an hour their effective teaching
tools but they've got it they learned
from some pedagogy purse
this is what you do and and they're
almost like you know it's interesting
because academics portray themselves as
being like totally open minded totally
you know look at the evidence and stuff
like that most of them are not that at
all most of them have their little
little thing that they do and that's it
now I have some unfortunate and that I
have some some quite a that I've taught
I've had some good colleagues who I
really like and can connect with and we
can have some great conversations and
but me and so many of them are like kind
of time servers or or you know they they
understand their little thing and that's
about it and everything else is crap
both according to them so that those are
some of my complaints all right
let's see that's the year so Brian has a
crazy question
would you kill a hooker for a billion
dollars if you were guaranteed to get
away with it no I wouldn't and it
doesn't matter whether it's a hooker or
somebody else it wouldn't kill somebody
for for money ah let's see
Oh although we end on this one
still good any recommendations for
someone who really enjoyed Rainer Maria
Rilke his letters to a young poet yeah
so if you liked his letters to a young
poet you probably would like to read
some of his other letters and you can
find his other letters and you will find
you know understandably enough him
treating similar themes like solitude
you know Ines am kite in these other
letters to other people from over the
course of his lifetime
you should also you know read his poems
if you haven't read his poems read some
of them and and I wouldn't say start
with the later stuff I would say start
with the Book of Hours those are some
really beautiful poems
and they will they will stick with you
and if you can read them in the German
read them in the German and and read
them aloud to yourself if you can't then
get multiple translations so you can see
what what he's he's driving at and then
you know at some point in time you do
want to read his Duino elegies those are
some really you know wonderful
metaphysical stuff to check out there
but I would start with you know reading
around in his other letters that would
probably be quite enjoyable for you you
you would you'd find some really
interesting bits of things there and
then you can start putting together a
more complex picture of who this guy is
and what he's thinking about and how he
connects poetry and philosophy the other
thing I'll mention too is I've never
actually heard this stuff but apparently
Gabrielle Marcel the French
existentialist thinker he took some of
Wilkins Petrine set it to music I would
love to find out more about that myself
maybe maybe you'll find out about that
so alright I didn't get to everybody's
questions but that's kind of unavoidable
because the longer that I stay on here
the more questions there are I wonder if
I did like a marathon session if that
would ever come to an end
so that is what I'm going to end on I
have another thing coming up tomorrow
I'm gonna do that in this same format
with a you know live streaming
we passed the 500 no we reached the 500
video mark passing would be 501 I
reached the 500 video mark in the core
concepts video series earlier this week
and so we're gonna have a little bit of
a celebration I'm gonna talk about the
series and why I got started with it and
and you know what I've learned along the
way and who I'm gonna do next in the
series so if you want to join me
tomorrow for o'clock Central Time
I'll be here for that and we'll have you
know of course our philosophy pop ups
Lee
in the month as well and other online
events you can find them easily on my
reason il calendar or you know patreon
supporters you already know what the
online events are so I'm gonna say sign
off now and hope all of you have a great
afternoon if you're in this area morning
evening whatever it is that you're doing